today we had a very nice surprise your
wife brought your relatively new
daughter you said more about king size
more the chub lord what my daughter you
set your nickname for you always have
these strange nicknames that are you
know it's not like oh hi winky dear or
hers little pooh bear your nicknames go
on for like 15 minutes yeah can i hear
some of them well there's bill squishman
founder squishman enterprises co-founder
siegel squishman dynamics quality
through cuteness
nice
the golden state pooper
by the time you get done saying the
first one she's like out the gate and
down the road where'd she go
she took off a half an hour ago when i
started her nickname
all right let's hear another one the
peepee queen of pasadena
king sizemore the chub lord
wow
king size what king sizemore the chub
lord okay very good mrs squeaks cheeks
for weeks
captain howdy lip so pouty glennomy
glenn the friend um i have a list let me
see you weren't reading from a list
right there no
those are just off the top of my head
yeah let's call these up
sure and pull this out uh master blaster
that's when she's breastfeeding
when she's breastfeeding and is this
from the beyond thunderdome master
blaster
is the idea that she's the little uh
creature that is controlling your wife
yeah okay he by the way lived in an
apartment in my hometown what the actor
who played him yeah who played master
blaster who played master of master
blaster
because it was a little person on top of
a big yes i remember oh i remember
master blaster quite well yeah he lived
in your building no he lived in an
apartment building in whittier where i
grew up okay
by the way useful digression
one of your bet one of your better
kaiju
and pazuzu's petals um mayday
dimpleton drool beard
uh
and i think that's that's about it for
now okay
is there a way i could get her a
therapist now
because she's going to need a therapy
she's because you're an insufferable man
i'm sure yes you're around going home
it's glenna glenda gugu
here comes little miss molly she's jolly
bali golly wally right there ali bali
stali write that down you seem so happy
uh
you know we walked in today to our
podcast studio and you've got this
beautiful girl and you seem happy you
seem legitimately happy you know
it enrages me
like how do i i had a kid just to be
this happy so i could enrage you yes
well it worked yeah
it worked that's fanta no it's fantastic
and by the way they'll come a day later
on when your children are older because
my children are older they're in their
late 40s
but they'll come by and they won't be
that interested in coming and seeing you
at work i remember when my kids would
come and visit me as little you know i'd
bring my daughter
to uh
to work when i was at rockefeller center
during the late night show and
uh i remember just her looking at all
the cameras and thinking this is so
amazing and um now it would just all get
an eye roll really all of this yeah
everything i do that's gonna break my
heart when your daughter
finds what you do is boring yeah yeah
that's what that's what happens though
no i just i i don't care she can't find
what i do boring but just that she's not
interested to spend time together i'm
already oh that's going to happen very
soon matt much earlier for you than most
parents what do you mean are you kidding
me no because you're gonna we're fast
friends we're buddies we're chums no no
you're not you're gonna say oh look at
these really cool
i got these really great porcelain mugs
at the rose bowl swap meet they were
built in the made in the 50s and but
look at the ridge right here on the
handle isn't that cool that's a that's a
you know
that's a right you know russell wright
made these and they're made of you know
and you'll just go on and on about this
board game that you found it's really
cool and it's got eisenhower in it and
and
you've got another year with your
daughter where she's really enjoying her
time with you the minute she can
decipher these ridiculous nicknames
you're it's you're over well they're
indecipherable so we got we're good
okay yeah it's uh i just i encourage you
i encourage you
to start planning now okay for the time
the dead time
it's tough it's tough they and the thing
is it's healthy you want them oh yeah
you want them to
individuate that's the word my wife
keeps saying it's important that our
children individually yeah i won't force
any of this stuff on her i promise you
know how i got my children to
individuate from me oh i'm awful
it's a little method i came up with
called being awful
i'm learning they're very happy to leave
the nest
when papa is an awful awful man
you